القصف الاسرائيلي على عياده ومركز ايواء
يتبع للور وعدد من الشهداء سقط في هذا
القصف
الاسرائيلي الان يتم انتشال الشهداء
والاصابات من مركز من داخل مركز ايواء
النازحين بعد انص قوات
الاح بشكل
مباشر ايش صار يا
حجه نايمين مش حدا كان ما شفنا الخبط في
المبنى اطفال وشيوخ وفلام ما بيقدروش
ينزلوا مش حرام مش
ظلم بس يا عالم
ابعدوا
بالله الراحه لا ال الا خلص ز
دوا بالرحمه يا اخوان بالرحمه هذه اثار
القصف
الاسرائيلي التي استهدف مركز لاواء
النازحين هذه الحاجيات واغراض النازحين
بعد القصف الكال الذي نجم عن استهداف قوات
الاحتلال لعياده الوكاله في حي الدرج تم
انتشال شهيد ايضا في داخل العياده ونفس
العياده
نشاهد بصوره اوضح اثار القصف الاسرائيلي
في الطابق الاخر هو الذي استهدف بشكل
مباشر هذا المكان هو مكان لاواء النازحين
تم
استهداف النازحين في هذا
المكان بشكل مباشر عدد من الشهداء
والاصابات نجم عن هذا القصف
الاسرائيلي لعياده الدرج التابعه للنور
ومدرسه الدرج ايضا التابعه
للنور تم استهداف هذه العيله بشكل مباشر
هذا المكان الذي ياوي الاطفال والنساء
هروبا من القصف الاسرائيلي فلا حقهم القصف
الاسرائيلي الى هذا المكان
[موسيقى]
ايضا هروبا من الموت الى الموت اتت هذه
العائله الى مركز ايواء النازحين التابع
للاونروا لكن قوات الاحتلال قصفت هذا
المركز بشكل مباشر دون سابق انظار اسماعيل
الغول قناه الجزيره مدينه غزه